hey 42 here okay now i know what you're
thinking
it's obvious what the most terrifying
creature in the water is
it's the great white shark everyone
knows that
but things aren't quite that clear-cut
as we're about to find out
in 1963 clinton haynes was scuba diving
in the deep and ancient nelson lakes new
zealand
in search of a lost propeller he
descended 30 meters into the inky
blackness
searching by torchlight for any sign of
his prize
a glint of reflected light from metal
perhaps
or an unusual shape on the lake bed what
he found instead
was something much much worse
a large dark shape uncoiled from the
shadows and began to move
rapidly towards him haynes drew his
knife as four more shapes appeared out
of the darkness
making the beeline straight for him he
had no idea what the creatures were
but he knew instinctively that he had
just dropped several links down the food
chain
in a breathless flurry of bubbles he
dropped his torch and fled for the
surface
where his wife was waiting for him in
their dinghy
as he raced upwards one of the black
shapes seized his flipper in its jaws
glancing down haynes caught a glimpse of
a gigantic
snake-like creature about two meters
long thrashing
below horrified he struggled with all
his might to escape
its clutches knowing at any moment the
animal's nightmarish pals would
reach him and together drag him
to his death breaking the surface he
screamed for his wife to help
seeing her husband grappling with a
curling monstrosity
she reacted instantly lunged forward and
with adrenaline fuelled superhuman
strength
hauled him out of the water the creature
fled back beneath the waves
and having risen from the depths too
quickly haynes passed out from
decompression sickness
but he was alive and safe
but just what manner of creature had
haunted him
these were no snakes neither were they
a manifestation of the tanifa from maori
mythology
said to eat men whole and carry their
wives into the depths
it was a group of lungfin eel
one of the largest eel species in the
world
looking like the product of an
ill-advised night of passion between a
snake
and a slug lungfin eels are powerful
swimmers
that would be more than capable of
drowning a fully grown man
haynes had a very lucky escape
these eels are so badass that they only
breed once
lest they take over the world just
before they
shuffle off this mortal coil they make a
final journey
thousands of kilometers from new zealand
to tonga
here the female lays up to 20 million
eggs
which once fertilized hatch into
alien-like transparent lava
called leptocephalus over the next 15
months
these larvae drift on ocean currents
back to new zealand
where they slowly transform into
transparent
glass seals and finally lung thin
heels now the first image that comes to
mind when i talk about
terrors of the deep is probably the
looming silhouette of a great white
shark
but look stop getting ahead of yourself
there are plenty of other foul beasties
out there
just as deserving of the accolade as
scariest monster from the deep
and some of the sneakiest have even
managed to disguise themselves
as our friends killer whales the aptly
named
wolves of the sea are typically
considered to be friendly
to humans probably because those bizarre
seaworld types
love nothing more than riding around on
their backs and launching into the air
off their noses
but in reality these animals are frankly
lethal killer whales are in fact not
really
whales at all but are instead the
largest member of the dolphin family
known for their incredible intelligence
unparalleled hunting ability
and insatiable punch on for sado
masochism
okay so i don't exactly have a source on
that last one
but come on they're basically just big
dolphins in suits
killer whales or orcas as they're also
known
named for orcus the roman god of death
and the underworld
naturally are well known for toying with
their prey
giving whatever hapless creature happens
to be on the menu
just enough of a head start to believe
it has a chance at life
before casually tearing it to shreds and
gulping down the bones
they've even been known to use half dead
prey
as a makeshift ball in the world's most
odious game of water polo propelling
half
dead seals some 20 meters into the air
just for the hell of it they hunt pretty
much anything that's stupid enough to
get in their way
enormous man-eating leopard seals no
problem
spawn of satan great white sharks easy
peasy
entire pods of humpback whales
yep i'll eat the kids first
the name killer whale is actually a
shortened form
of killer of whales because that's
exactly what they do
they swim around in formation
slaughtering
sperm huntback grey finn
and any other whales they come across
they even eat other dolphins because
what better way of remaining the most
feared member of the dolphin family
than by indiscriminately slaughtering
the competition
in shores they have what you might call
a resume of terror
they can grow to be eight meters long
and weigh in at five and a half thousand
kilos
they are hyper hyper-intelligent and
have evolved extremely complex
and efficient team-based hunting methods
that employ special forces tactics
like flushing flanking and ambushing
they have complex social structures
which they use to teach their young
their species ancient and sophisticated
murder techniques
and they possess an understanding of
physics that would make a phd student
blush
allowing them to generate waves designed
to knock seals off ice floes
and into the salivating mouths of their
pals
but somehow because they can do
backflips in water parks and
majestically leap over rock walls to
freedom
we consider them little more than
friendly oversized ocean dogs
even though tilly arguably the most
infamous captive killer whale
ever is known to have violently murdered
free human beings at sea world parks
two of which were his trainers although
it must be said keeping killer whales in
captivity is known to have serious
adverse effects on their mental
well-being
and by doing so you're kind of asking
for it
plus there have been no recorded fatal
attacks by killer whales on humans in
the wild
then again maybe that's because they're
too intelligent to get caught
whilst killer whales may be giving
mankind a wide berth
the same can't be said for sperm whales
which are
perhaps the embodiment of the ocean's
vengeance upon mankind
whilst most of the time their docile
creatures
sperm whales can rapidly turn into 12
meters and almost 60
000 kilos of cetacean destruction
sperm whales are the largest animal with
teeth
on the planet each of their 50 odd teeth
measures up to 20 centimeters in length
and weighs as much as a kilo
what do they use these gigantic teeth
for doing battle with the ungodly
colossal squid
for the most part but they don't just
have to rely on a set of gnashes that
ronaldinho would be proud of to take
down their prey
they also make use of an integrated
sound cannon
so powerful it produces the loudest
sound
of any animal on earth at 230 decibels
it's louder than a jet engine so loud in
fact
it can blow your eardrums to smithereens
or
even if you're stupid enough to get in
close
vibrate you to death sperm whales also
have the largest brain of any living
animal
including your own by the way as 8 000
cubic centimeters sperm whale brains are
on average five times larger than ours
with a far more complex cerebral cortex
indicating they can feel a range of
emotions from
empathy and joy to love
and even vengeance they're also
exceptionally strong
a gentle flick from the tail of a
juvenile can instantly kill a man
and the strength of a fully grown sperm
whale's flukes
are so respected by whalers they refer
to it
as the hand of god probably because if
one hits their boat
they will all be off to meet him in 1820
a massive sperm whale attacked the
whaling ship
essex ramming her repeatedly until
she began to sink only eight of the 21
crew members survived
the shipwreck another famous sperm whale
mocha dick was an old albino ball of
remarkable size and strength
he was said to have killed 30 men and
was covered in scar tissue and puncture
wounds from harpoons
mocha dick would often charge whalers
directly
taking them head-on to distract them
from the females in his pod
he endured hundreds of encounters like
this saving countless of his kind
and blasting small boats to splinters
with his thundering flukes
if whaler legends are to be believed
when mocha dick was struck with a
harpoon
he would single out the man responsible
and personally send him to hell
fitting revenge considering we used to
massacre
5000 of his kind per year to turn them
into candles
when he was finally brought down in 1838
the whalers found 19 harpoons
embedded in his enormous body these two
stories the sinking of the essex
and trail of destruction left by the
white whale mocha dick
are thought to have inspired herman
melville's 1851 novel
moby dick and when i say fought to have
it isn't like old hermann tried overly
hard to cover his tracks
mucker dick moby dick i'd have failed
him for plagiarism in a heartbeat
but massive god forsaken whales aren't
the only towers of the deep
there are also a whole bunch of strange
unclassifiable oddities that are
horrifying revolting and dangerous
in equal measure there are flesh-eating
amphipods that consume any organic
matter they come across and have been
known to chow down on the legs of unwary
swimmers
there are sea spiders with unsettlingly
lung legs
that can grow up to 70 centimeters
across
and and command with a straw-like
proboscis
that allows them to suck the insides out
of unwary prey
then there are zombie worms that emerge
from the decaying bones of whales
like living veins and
vampire squid from hell that is their
real name
they aren't actually all that terrifying
but for some reason they have a name
like a 1950s b
movie there's the goblin shark a frankly
disturbing
deep sea monster with a lung snout and
catapulting jaws
that it uses to devour prey whole
oh and don't forget the kandiroo
a small parasitic catfish that will
according to some swim up your urethra
and eat your penis from the inside out
that's right gents you don't have to
visit a bangkok brothel
for a parasite to eat your genitals
colossal and giant squid arch nemesis
of mocha dick and friends are examples
of the zoological phenomenon
of abyssal gigantism which is the
tendency
for deep sea invertebrates to grow to
the size of godzilla villains
the colossal squid a monstrous
kraken-like creature
is the bigger of the two and is in fact
the heaviest living invertebrate species
it can reach lengths of more than 10
meters can weigh as much as 700
kilograms
and sports the largest eyes of any
animal
almost 30 centimeters across all are
better to scare the out of you with
colossal and giant squid are very rarely
seen near the surface
and much of what we know about them
comes from the half-digested remains
found in the bellies of sperm whales
both species are living proof that the
further down you go
the more awful things get speaking of
the oceanic abyss
go down as far as 3 500 meters
you might be unfortunate enough to come
face to face
with baffy asaurus ferox otherwise known
as the deep sea lizard fish undoubtedly
one of the ugliest creatures to ever
inflict
itself on planet earth with a snake-like
head
and vacant soulless eyes its dozens of
needle-like teeth appear to have been
expertly designed
by satan to keep prey held in a
vice-like
grip that only tightens the more the
victim struggles
pretty terrifying right but what's that
i hear you say
no ugly fish or overweight squid could
possibly be as terrifying
as the great white shark the most
perfect killing machine imaginable
outside of a ridley scott film well
don't be too hasty
because whilst a cone snail is
admittedly
only small like the legendary beast that
waits
in the cave of kierbanog
there's more to this cute critter than
meets the eye
no he doesn't have nasty big pointy
teeth
but he does possess a venom so powerful
that a single drop
can kill 20 men and his nickname
the cigarette snail comes from the fact
that you'll only have time to smoke
a single cigarette once you've been
injected with it
which by the way happens via a
harpoon-like appendage
the cone snail can launch at its victims
at 400 miles per hour
in humans the venom causes muscle
paralysis
distorted vision and total respiratory
failure
unsurprisingly this is a snail that
fears nothing
except perhaps the french and
gun toting snails aren't the only
venomous monstrosities
waiting for us out there in the water no
i'm not talking about the children's
entertainer on a budget cruise ship
but and hydrina skistoster
commonly known as the beaked sea snake
which herpetologists that's experts on
lizards
not stds describe as cantankerous
and savage this aggressive little
bastard
is responsible for more than half of all
sea snake bites worldwide
and up to 90 percent of fatalities
what michael jordan was to dunking
basketballs
the beet sea snake is to filling hapless
swimmers with
lethal venom they usually hang out in
india
and can dive up to 100 meters so even
scuba divers aren't safe
they can stay underwater for five hours
hunting fish
and looking for people to kill they
frequently get caught up in nets
where unsuspecting fishermen's hands
become the target of
a venom injection more potent than that
of a cobra
or rattlesnake a single bite injects up
to
9 milligrams of venom when 1.5 milligram
is more than enough to kill you then
there's the australian box jellyfish a
gelatinous transparent
tentacled orb that's responsible for an
estimated 100 or more human fatalities
per year
equipped with powerful stingers and
multiple eye clusters
these lovecraftian monstrosities
actively hunt down prey
which is rare amongst jellyfish and just
one of them
packs enough venom to kill 60 humans
a sting from a boxed jellyfish is said
to be agonizingly painful
can cause your cells to leak potassium
and can cause heart failure in as little
as
two minutes as we've seen there's a lot
of terrifying animal life
waiting to eat poison drown or dismember
you
in the sea but of all the creatures that
lurk beneath the waves
only one can be the most terrifying
okay yeah it's the great white shark
carca the undisputed
king of ocean terror and
why wouldn't it be just look at this
thing
this is a monster so terrifying it has
its own dedicated theme tune
that plays the second you find yourself
in deep water
or so i'm told the great white shark is
an ancient killing machine
that has hardly evolved in millions of
years after all
how can you improve upon perfection it
is the largest predatory fish
in existence over six meters and a
thousand
kilograms of seal destroying evil that
haunts coastal waters
waiting to rip the legs off unsuspecting
surfers
great whites are responsible for more
shark attacks and fatalities
than any other shark species in the
ocean
here are just a few examples of the
destruction these guys can cause
shirley and durden were searching for
scallops off the coast of australia
when a six metre great white smashed
into her
ripping her in half whilst her terrified
husband and children watched on
when the frothing bloodied water cleared
all that remained
was her decapitated mutilated torso
and by the time the emergency services
showed up
the shark had eaten that too omar hunger
and his friend chris rheem were relaxing
in the pacific ocean
off the coast of the united states when
an enormous great white
grabbed conga propelling him out of the
water like a ragdoll
before dragging him back under seconds
later the shark exploded back to the
surface
tossing conga's lacerated body aside
although the two men made it to shore
the terrible injuries congress sustained
would soon end his life lloyd skinner
was swimming in the neck
deep water just off the coast of cape
town
when an enormous great white shark the
size of a mini bus got hold of him
dragging him underwater a pair of
swimming goggles
bobbing for lonely amongst the waves is
all i was ever found of him
just recently a woman was killed in
maine while swimming 18 meters offshore
with her daughter
and a month before that a man was killed
spear fishing in australia
the fourth victim in the country this
year
great whites are incredibly adept ambush
predators
preferring to take their prey by
surprise from below
striking it up to 35 miles per hour with
enough force to launch themselves clean
out of the water
and up to three meters into the air they
have no trouble tracking down their
victims either
as they're able to detect a single drop
of blood
from up to three miles away and if you
were thinking of trying to escape
i'm afraid you're out of luck the great
white can swim around
ten times faster than a human being not
even
michael phelps would be in with a shout
they are
finely tuned killing machines so deadly
they're completely self-sufficient from
birth
as soon as they're born they swim away
from their mothers and get
busy murdering things something which
continues
for the next 70 years of their
blood-drenched lives
you would be wise not to wear reflective
jewelry in deep water
as great white mistake this for fish
scales
and will make a bee well shark line
directly towards you and if it does trap
you in its 4000 psi of biting force
apparently your best option is to
manically punch it in its eyeball
where it's most vulnerable so
if you ever glimpse the unmistakable
shadow of a great white shark beneath
you in the ocean
may god have mercy on your soul because
it
certainly won't thanks for watching
you can now pre-order my brand new book
sticker flag in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you